[Music]
this
is ohsu
shaped by leaders pioneers
and those brave enough to take that
first step
we carry the torch and shine a light on
what is possible
we are a collaboration of disciplines
listening to one another learning from
each other
the ohsu clinical informatics phd
program
is more than an opportunity to gain
experience
it's your time to serve with a community
of trailblazers
and groundbreakers i learned about the
field
of informatics as i was finishing my
training in internal medicine
and i thought this is for me it combines
medicine it combines computers and
information
as soon as i got into it and started
doing the work i realized that this was
my calling in life this this combination
of medicine and information like
most phd programs you typically do a
dissertation where you focus in
on a specific area of research and
oftentimes you take that area of
research with you into the work that you
perform
and so the goal really is to become a
researcher a thought leader
in informatics our phd program
is one of 16 around the country that's
funded by the national library medicine
which is the part of the national
institutes of health
that funds research training in
biomedical informatics
part of the challenge with informatics
is that
there's so many aspects usually to any
project that you need someone who really
understands electronic health records
and you need somebody else who really
understands
information retrieval and you need
someone who understands
how to make the systems talk to each
other it's
not a solo kind of area we're looking
for people that have kind of a natural
research curiosity
someone who is self-driven the win-win
situation is when a student comes in and
says gosh karen i'm really interested in
this area and i can say
gee you should go talk to professor x a
lot of my work is around like
image-based
informatics doing stuff with a disease
called retinopathy or prematurity
everyone here is very passionate about
what they do
um it's it's pretty remarkable actually
you learn a lot obviously but then
there's also like a
very like personal connection with
people too that you kind of build and
you can tell the people are are there
not just to get you through the program
but they're there for you
right now i'm working on a project um
where i'm working with pulmonology in
the cystic fibrosis
adult care center to learn more about
the ways that wildfire smoke affects
the health of people with cystic
fibrosis
i'm also working with the department of
family medicine
on a research project that's looking at
social determinants of health
julie i found ohsu to be like a really
great place
if you're an intellectually curious
person where it very much rewards
intellectual curiosity and where there's
lots of people who want
to teach you things and want to give you
those opportunities
you get in here and everyone has
different backgrounds so i personally
had a biochemistry background i know
people have
biology backgrounds there are people
with math backgrounds computer science
backgrounds
so it's funny where we'll get into a
class you know that's maybe
centered around computer science or
something like that and those people
seem to excel and the rest of us are
like oh what is all this you know but
then you get into a
class that's more biology related and
you start excelling in the
the cs people are like ah what is this
you know so
it's fun like because then you can work
together and you can all
help each other and teach each other
along the way all the students
do at least two research rotations with
different faculty members
so that they get a chance to learn hey
do i like working with karen
do i like the area of research maybe i
like to work
with paul or maybe i like to work with
joan so it gives them a chance to
learn what the other faculty members are
doing in terms of research
i would consider what sort of academic
environment you want to be in
it's a great program if you
have a lot of your own motivation and
something that you're willing
to pursue i don't think that you need to
be a tech geek at all
in fact i was interested in technology
but i didn't know anything about
programming
before i came here and i've learned so
much and i love it now
ohsu is a very collaborative community i
think that
one of the strengths of our institution
is that there is
a lot of common mission and mutual
respect for each other whether you're a
clinician
or a researcher or an educator or
someone who's working in informatics who
may be part
of any of those groups what they tell
you in like the open house formats or
anything like that
it's pretty candid you'll hear from us i
don't think there's
there aren't any secrets that you know
we're holding back or being
hushed up about it's it's a phd program
it's
if you're passionate about it you're
gonna do great uh it's not easy at all
times but
it's yeah it's where you wanna be then
you should be here
at some point it's about the why you do
what you do
as much as the how
we do it because we are bold
we do it because someone needs to make
the difference
and we know we can make the difference
because we already
have we welcome the curious
inspired and those willing to be bold
this is ohsu